Michael tall how many of you heard
played over the games of Michael tall
okay now that's a kind of an interesting
question is like um what people's
perception of Michael tall was and the
popular meme is that tall was this a
crazy guy man he just loved to sacrifice
his pieces and he just throw his pieces
and palms at you and most of his
combinations were unsound or just barely
and they were so complex and complicated
as opponent got in trouble and time
trouble and problems and they collapsed
because like this hurricane this force
of nature and it's interesting because
that wasn't the way I saw him at all but
there was a period there where I think
Michael tall played like a t-80 a t-top
world class international grandmasters
and went undefeated well oh excuse me
did you say undefeated I mean isn't this
the swashbuckling debonair you know guy
who's throwing ponds and pieces at
everybody
you don't go undefeated with that type
of style this is like a rock solid guy
you know one of the things was that he
was really really good at combinations
okay
this made him world champion okay and
where did this extraordinary ability a
combinations come from okay so in this
game
Michael tall is white fm Geller one of
the world's strongest grandmasters was
blah
FM Geller's you know how to plus score
against Bobby Fischer so he's not a bad
player this player on the black side
this game was played in 1958 in the USSR
championship or the chant in the
national championship of the Soviet
Union in round 12 and the game continued
along very normal patterns of what is
called of course the Rui Lopez Bishop b5
a6 Bishop a4 Knight f6 castles Bishop g7
rook e1 so we reach right now what is
probably one of the most analyzed as
well as most played positions of all
time the most classical variation of the
King's pawn opening the Rui lope has and
it's very it's very interesting the
vagaries of fashion today a Levon
Aronian
Micky Adams and many other people love
to play the Marshall gambit so that that
gambit of course occurs this is second
let me move some things around for a
moment the Marshall gambit of course
occurs after castles yes in variation c3
d5 pond takes d5 Knight takes d5 and we
have the gambit made most famous by
Frank Marshall ok today a lot of players
like to play black black side I do you
all know the myth the the story behind
the Marshall gambit yeah United Julian
what's what's the version you know
yes that's correct
so first of all Frank Marshall in the
1900s 1930s was one of America's
greatest players American champion and
he played in the world's elite players
and it was very common for him in fact
that's what he did is he went to bed a
tent on his bedside table he had a
little notebook and a pencil and very
often times he had dreams about chats
and he would wake up and realize that he
had an idea and that was why he had the
notebook so he would critically scribble
his idea of her waking up and so he had
this position in his mind and he began a
series for many years to play the black
side of the position now today the
modern way of playing the Marshall
gambit is to play c6 maintaining the
knight on d5 and after d4 Bishop d6 rook
e1 Queen h4 we have many many many moves
of the Marshall gambit still to go so
that's the modern day treatment well
Frank Marshall had a completely
different idea than maintaining his
Knight here
instead he dropped his Knight back to F
sex with a completely different idea in
mind what his idea was that is he wanted
to put his bishop on d6 attack this rook
horse the rook to go back sacrifice his
bishop on h2 and after King takes H to
play Knight g4 and so on
and he analyzed this whole idea in
secret for years and he sprang it on the
world champion Jose Raul kappa blanka
and kappa blanka literally spent about
an hour in this position the game
continued and the world champion kappa
blanka refuted Marshalls idea over the
board I mean dull image is terrible
right you know these LED years preparing
an idea and the guy was so good he found
the proper attic them anyway they agrees
of chess theory are like fashion and
they come and go but at the time of this
game by far the most played move the
simply d7 d6 not going for the Marshall
gambit c3 castles and then at times this
move d4 becomes popular the idea of D
for many many games go d4 Bishop g4 and
d5 a knight here and so forth and so on
and after h3 excuse me oops sorry C 6 H
3 Bishop c8 tons of games have been
played like this and the overall view
point is is that black is doing fine and
so the move d4 not the main move is
replaced by the million move h3 so in
this position again we're still in chess
theory that goes from many many moves
from here in the 18th and 19th century
there was the guy Chu Goren and this is
chigorin's move Knight a5 the idea is
that the knight on c6 inhibits the pawn
on c7 so the knight moves so that the
pawn can advance and the knight moves
with a tempo against the bishop so all
of these moves once again have been
played and in this position there's a
ton of moves original chigorin idea of
returning the knight to c6
Smith laughs Queen c7 there's 97 and
again at the time that this game was
played in 1958 Bishop d7 was very
popular so there's many approaches to
this position I'd encourage you to read
Bobby Fischer's my 60 memorable games as
Bobby himself will will explain all
about what happens when you capture the
pawn and Knight takes e5 the whole idea
is that capturing this pawn in the words
of Walter Brown immediately does not
benefit wide after night after Queen
takes d8 rook takes d8 Knight takes e5
the idea is that this pawn on e4 which
looks like it's very nicely protected in
fact is not black can capture on e4
takes tags tags and oops there's a check
at the end of the line and nice double
attack against the night and but Bishop
d6 check and black is doing excellently
yeah okay so if the pawn on e5 isn't
hanging after the move Bishop b7 one
thing that Y can consider is closing the
position with the move d5 and that's a
whole different branch of theory in this
game b4 was played and that was popular
at the time takes takes Knight here
Knight d2 okay
so we're still in theory and there's a
lot of possibilities here for black of
what he might play or what he might
consider but at that time the very
suggested d5 right boom you know blowing
up look at this look at this
explosiveness in the center all the
pawns can capture one another and they
consider the considered opinion of the
terrorists at that time was that black
was doing just fine in this position and
with this move defied by the way black
is opening up this Bishop on e7 that is
otherwise a little bit passive and this
Bishop looks terrific
so in short Geller's a happy camper
okay takes on d5 takes on d4 takes takes
takes takes okay so uh blacks happy
right blacks happy in blacks mind he's
ready to play Queen takes d5 winning
upon the rook is under fire and
what is white going to do what this game
for me was about was this extraordinary
ability to ignore the opponent threat in
other words to impose what you want to
do on your opponent that you ignore your
opponent's threat and you create threats
of your own this is an extraordinary
example of literally imposing your will
on the position rook b1 attacking the
bishop Julian yes Bishop g5 is an
excellent move as well Bishop g5 pinning
the knight to the Queen
basically Bishop Tate well let's have a
look so we can see what what Julian has
in mind let me see
I actually what's our e I actually want
to hide how do I then how I hide the
notation training good he has the simple
question get a simple answer
okay so we've sacrificed in exchange and
now this is a line that undoubtedly
Michael tall had to analyze he had to
weigh the scales here he sees that
Bishop takes f6 well first of all he's
an exchange down is the upon mountain oh
heavens he has it yet he sees that
Bishop takes f6 that that's a very nasty
pin and he calculates something like
Queen takes d5 Bishop takes f6 Queen
takes d4 Bishop takes d4 Bishop takes f3
G takes that's really satisfied with his
position
he sees something like Bishop takes d5
Bishop takes f6 G takes f6 Queen h4 with
a nice deadly threat against the pawn on
h7 and once more he's satisfied with his
position the better he starts to wonder
how effective how good is the exchange
sacrifice is if black plays a move like
Queen b6 getting out of our pen are we
going to play Bishop takes Queen takes
and Queen takes is a pond sufficient for
the exchange he's not so sure but he
takes this position well Julian you've
asked about and he asked themselves a
different question what in that position
that we were just looking at for a
moment if instead of having a rook on e1
we had a rook on b7 let's see how that
changes the dynamics sorry
instead of Bishop g5 rook b1 Bishop
takes rook takes now rooks on b7 kind of
like nice I mean that's nice more
importantly we've got a big threat
Knight takes a 1 and okay let's see
what's going on you can take the pawn
but then it's going to cost you your
bishop so Goeller defends his paw bishop
pardon me rook e8
and Michael pal says I like my I like my
pot so with this move d6 we're still
unsure how many of you think the
exchange sacrifice is justified and it's
it's a good position for for white how
many think hey man black didn't do
anything wrong that you know he's played
all logical move so far so the position
must be good for black yeah pretty good
pretty pretty even and this is the kind
of a strange thing about a lot of tall's
sacrifices is that in fact he had really
superb judgment in terms of factoring in
the dynamic that the dynamic
possibilities in the position so after
this move d7 d6 well in the first place
it opens up the possibility of Queen
takes c4 Queen takes f7 check and
checkmate on g7 second of all this is
kind of nice to have a pawn on d6 yeah
and if if we could ever play Queen take
C form Bishop b3 well our attack against
the f7 pawn is really going to be brutal
and finally not to put too fine a point
on it because we do want to maintain
this thread of knight takes he won there
even exists ideas of Knight g5 and
Knight e5 going after the f7 pawn but
basically with Queen takes c4 with a
pawn and a bishop for the exchange as
well as a rook on the seventh rank
White's whole attacking idea I think is
fully justified and for that reason
Gellar played the MU queen c8
just attacking the rook on b7 but
guarding his pawn on on c4 now again at
this point I think Gellar was pretty
happy okay just like you know and as the
Soviet championship
he's an exchange ahead
it's a little bit weird we're not a
hundred percent sure about whites
compensation and to my mind tal played
an extraordinary move here what move did
Michael tal make with the white pieces
well let me start you off by saying that
the logical move and to move that I
think most grandmasters would play is
rook c7
needless to say tall did not make this
move pal did not play rook c7 and I
think that after rook c7 Queen e6 the
game would pretty much go into a draw
how did I analyze that to a draw Oh hmm
okay
I had analyzed this to a draw no I'm not
too sure how I did it I scratch what
okay I think I played the move Knight g5
attacking the Queen and Queen to d5 I
think
Bishop takes h7 Shaq King h8 how did I
do this damn I'm not sure um I'll come
to the how come back to this point yes
young man you had a question did you yes
okay aha uh-huh okay so you had an idea
but you checked yourself you saw the
solution as well okay
Michael tall played a remarkable move we
should be fine well I mean just like
hangs rook right but what is it what is
it that that it's not just courage and
creativity and knowledge what was it
that cadet that compelled Michael tall
to play this move Bishop g5 just
thoughts just what do you think how did
Michael I mean how did Michael tall in
this position come up with this move
yeah yeah that's exactly right then and
what the gentleman said was that there's
a lot of attackers there and that's what
often times Grand Master's and I think
everybody should actually just use this
simple formula defenders versus the
attackers right what's the ratio okay in
halls mind what he could see is that
when the bishop comes to f6 he's got
ideas of Bishop takes h7 check Knight g5
check or Bishop takes f6 Bishop takes
check King takes Queen comes across to
h4 comes to g5 mates on g7 so in Tal
mind what he's saying is he's attacking
with one two three four pieces blacks
defending with one two three because we
always count the King as a defender
right so in tiles mind this move Bishop
g5 is completely in this whole idea of
I'm going to attack you where you're
weak where you don't have pieces but I
just think that this move Bishop g5 is
just inspiring I mean like BAM you know
like and you have to imagine that
Geller's reaction has have been like you
know just blind shot like what's this
you know you didn't move his rook he
doesn't move this rock and there's
nothing that can throw you off so much
as an unexpected move and it's not just
cycle psychological but in reality it's
much harder to defend than it is to
attack right
I mean attacking you might find yourself
having a possibility that leads to a
force perpetual
Jack so you can bail out or you might
find a possibility of sacrificing more
but with the idea of winning whereas the
defender you might just only have this
very narrow path where you have to play
only moves so after Bishop g5 Geller
decided not to take the rook not to take
the rook but instead try to impose his
own threat I mean he's getting pushed
around pretty good right so now he's
trying to come back with this move
rookie - with a double attack against
the bishop on c2 and threaten to take
this pawn on f2 forking the Queen and
the king but let's see whether this
coffeehouse attack by Tall would have
what would have happened if he takes his
rook
okay so Bishop takes f6 and now we are
threatening to win on the spot for
example I'll just toss a move out just
to show what kind of threats White has
in the position
check-check
Queen here threatening checkmate and
it's that simple you get made it on the
dark squares either white will play
Queen here checkmate or queen can check
thing okay so let's imagine that black
captures the bishop on f6 now remember
this little pawn that had been back here
on the d5 square and from on the D Phi
square when it was here like there was a
knight takes there was a bishop takes or
there was a queen takes the pawn now
this little pawn on d6 do we notice what
it does in the position it guards the
square e seven guards the square e seven
what do I mean by that well how can
white get at blacks King that's a real
good move do you see the really good
loop like if we take a look at this
bishop on c2 it attacks the pawn on h7
so if we could put our queen on h7 or
the check the king would go here we
could go checkmate because the King
can't escape so we have Queen h4 correct
with the idea of taking this pawn
Black's only move would be King f8 would
allow us to go Queen check King Queen
takes check I think the only move is f5
correct okay so this is a this is very
very often I see this in tall's games
that he always has a draw right so like
in this position if there's not a win
you can see that white has a perpetual
check right so suddenly white realizes
that he's not taking a risk so when
you're playing and attacking and you can
see that you have a forced perpetual
check this is a really really big plus
for you right because you know you're
not taking any risk and maybe just maybe
there's more than a perpetual check how
many of you think is more than a
perpetual check okay and in fact there
is more than a perpetual check I think
the correct way gosh it's been a while
since I've seen this was Queen g5 check
King here I think we're supposed to go
here
does this make sense King here and we're
supposed to go Bishop takes and if I if
I've done it right I think that this is
the winning idea is to be able to play
Knight g5 and not allow f7 f6 by black
in other words if we go back to this
moment
it may seem correct
just to play Bishop takes f5 to once
again threaten to capture this pawn on
h7 here that this allows the defense f7
f6 and what and the Queen defends h7 so
that was why we made that little Queen
move instead so that f7 f6 isn't
playable and now we play Bishop takes f5
ok so we go back and Bishop g5 comes and
now rookie - ok so sports fans what did
Michael tall play don't all shout at
once well well sorry
yes
sorry uh Bishop takes f6 allows black to
so it was a dual threat the move rook
rook rook here has a girl threat well we
well let's let's start with the
elimination Knight takes rook takes King
h2 Queen takes b7 can't be good for for
for white because in the first place
we've just traded up one of our
attackers so that variation we saw a
moment ago isn't is no longer possible
the Knights been removed so Knight takes
is out one idea we might consider is d7
right d7 is a kind of a intriguing move
let's see what other ideas and the other
idea is simply in this position now we
protect our rook after the move rook c7
Bishop takes f2 check isn't a threat
we'll take hey take the Queen take the
rook and we'll be material ahead we'll
have two pieces for a rook Queen e6
Knight takes rook takes King here and
now and now even though the combination
is still ongoing we start to sum things
up first of all white has a pawn and two
bishops against the rook Knight still a
good attacking potential Bishop takes f6
d7 ideas are in the position and
unfortunately this moment well know this
move is fine rook d8 was a good move but
now after Bishop takes f6 gehler
probably in time trouble because
get FM gala was a was a notorious time
travel attic here he he blundered and
lost I I had analyzed something like
Queen takes f6 Queen takes f6 D takes f6
d7 King f8 Bishop takes rook here I
think I think this is right
King g3 rook takes Bishop f5 and I
actually like this ending for white in
the first place this pawn on d7 and this
Bishop on f5 combination really is worth
this rook on d8
secondly this rook being behind the past
pawn on c4 we can play rook here King e7
and rook takes whenever we want like and
in the meanwhile this pawn also is quite
dangerous for black so I thought that
this position was better for white or
rather White has the sunny side of maybe
a draw position but nonetheless gala
should have played that instead Geller
played G takes f6 and this is a blunder
way
what can what can Michael yes you know
it does it does that's exactly right
it does leave his king open but blacks
pieces are poised for a skier and we all
know what a skier is right Julian
so we skier by yes
rookie seven and black loses a piece of
course Geller saw the move rookie seven
and he understood that he can't move his
queen because rook takes rook wins for
white but what he anticipated was that
he was going to take the rook you right
so that after takes rook takes and it's
black who wins brilliantly yes but here
he suddenly had a realization that white
has a swishing Zook you know what at
wereld squishin zoo it's a German word
it means in between and a moment ago you
said that this move opens up blacks King
which it does white would move his queen
with check and only after the Queen has
moved with check the king is moving now
we can take the Queen and we win yeah
sweet so this is how the game finished
it white is a piece ahead of course and
he wins quite soon resigns nice huh nice
game nice game okay
oh boy that almost takes us to the end
of our lecture for the next for the next
lecture coming up after this I'm
actually going to use another game of
Michael Hall and he played one of the
most extraordinary moves of all times I
mean here I promise you if you guess -
move yeah sure could be a future world
champion